this imposing structure holds a special
place in the hearts of many kashmiris
for centuries the grand mosque has been
a venue for prayers and an arena for
political activism but has largely
remained closed for nearly two and a
half years
i come every friday for prayers but all
in vain the mosque remains closed i feel
sad and distressed we believe our
prayers will be answered if we pray at
the jamia masjid on fridays it used to
give me solace
kashmir is claimed in full by india and
pakistan but governed by the two nations
in parts indian administered kashmir has
seen protests and violent uprisings
against new delhi's rule for decades the
grand mosque has played a role in
driving these
in august 2019 the government revoked
kashmir special status and imposed a
communications blackout it also shut
mosques in this muslim-dominated region
while others have reopened the grand
mosque's leader has been detained in his
home and the grounds have remained out
of bounds for friday prayers
in the past tens of thousands of muslims
attended these
there are some elements that want to
disturb places like these and create an
impression internationally that muslims
are being suppressed in india i think
security agencies took these precautions
to prevent that
in the heart of the main city srinagar
the mosque is a major meeting point for
people who live here
sermons would address kashmir's
political struggles while authorities
have closed it for extended periods in
the past its closure now has raised
concerns about religious freedom
in these times we are seeing
unprecedented suppression pressure and
tyranny across india particularly in
kashmir where even religious gatherings
are not allowed our grand mosque plays a
central role in its closure negates
india's claims of secularism and
democracy
the government has also blamed the
pandemic and says it will ask local
authorities for a security review to
reopen the mosque but kashmiris are
skeptical and say new delhi has made
similar excuses in the past to crack
down on their freedoms
al-jazeera new delhi